dừng ngay cái việc uống cái trà lợi sữa này đi nhá
nếu mà thấy mà sữa nó đã về rồi ấy
các bà dừng ngay hoặc là các bà sẽ giảm xuống
một cái bình một lần thôi đây này
lần này chỉ cần một cái bình này thôi nha
chứ không lại giống tôi hôm trước
nó bị adeno xong rồi
bị tắc Tia á xong nó mất sữa xong rồi kích sữa lại
ngày uống Cho 2 bình liền
xong nó về nhiều quá nè
kích ơ sữa xong cái
chứ đông một đống bây giờ thằng con nó chẳng chịu uống
sữa mà để trong tủ lạnh trong ngăn đông ấy
nó rất là dễ bị xà phòng hóa
nó là một cái quá trình làm Cho
những cái chất béo ở bên trong sữa ấy nó bị xà phòng
và làm Cho cái sữa nó có cái mùi rất là kinh
thế là bây giờ bạn chẳng uống bây giờ biết làm gì hông
đang đi tắm bây giờ Ra đồng để tắm Cho bạn đây này
chứ không có uống nữa rồi
không đứa nào chịu uống hết trơn á
mà trong khi đó cái này á nó quý giá lắm
nó là máu của mình đó
nó là canxi là là sách của mình đó
nên là để như này là lãng phí quá
phải giữ lại cái sức khỏe Cho mình
chỉ vừa đủ Cho con ti thôi
đây bây giờ bỏ vô đi tắm nè
Cho vào đây để Cho nó giã đông đi xong rồi một lát nữa
sẽ tắm Cho hắn
tắm bằng sữa
thì các bà chú ý là mình sẽ giã đông Ra xong rồi
sau khi mà mình tắm bằng sữa xong
mình sẽ phải tắm thật sạch lại với nước sạch nha